en este vídeo espero que realmente se
entienda por qué la forma compleja no
más bien la forma exponencial de un
número complejo es realmente útil así
que digamos que queremos encontrar o que
queremos resolver la ecuación x cúbica
igual a 1 así que vamos a tratar de
hallar todas las raíces reales o
complejas de esta ecuación que es
equivalente a x cúbica menos 1 igual a 0
así que hallamos todas las raíces reales
o complejas de esta ecuación y bueno
realmente aquí es donde vamos a usar la
forma exponencial la técnica que vamos a
utilizar puede ser útil para cuando
tienes x a las 5 x a la 37 no importa lo
que quieres que veamos todos los
patrones que emergen al al checar esto
en el plano complejo es decir en el
plano cartesiano así que pensemos a z
como igual a 1 esta es una raíz es una
raíz
de la solución de esta ecuación así que
vamos a pensar las otras raíces que
pueda tener esta por supuesto no tiene
una parte imaginaria así que si la
dibujamos en el plano
digamos aquí tenemos mi eje real y el
eje imaginario entonces esto
es el eje real el eje imaginario y si
queremos representar esta zeta igual a 1
pues aquí lo colocamos sobre el eje real
verdad si por ejemplo aquí tenemos el 1
y menos 1 en ambos ejes pues bueno nos
fijamos que se está igual a 1 se
encuentra sobre el eje real es decir en
realidad tiene entradas en el plano 10
porque lo podemos escribir como 10 y muy
bien de esta forma lo podemos poner ahí
o en otras palabras su forma exponencial
tiene primero la magnitud de este vector
es una verdad la magnitud del vector es
1 ahora cuál es el argumento bueno el
argumento de z el argumento de z cuál es
el argumento de z cuál es el ángulo que
hace este vector con el eje real bueno
pues como es un número real
se encuentra en el eje así que no tiene
ángulo así que su argumento es z es
perdón es 0 así pero puede que esto no
parezca interesante pero si lo checamos
esto pongan atención esto sería 1 por e
a la 0 y verdad este su forma
exponencial y por supuesto a la 0 y es
uno simplemente era la cualquier más
bien cualquier cosa a la 0 es 1 no hay
gran problema el detalle es el siguiente
si tomamos 0 radiales en realidad es lo
mismo que tomar dos verdades como si le
diéramos una vuelta completa así que el
argumento de z en realidad puede no ser
sólo cero sino que además puede ser dos
para que le demos dos vueltas y sea
cuatro pi o le demos tres vueltas y sea
seis u ocho en fin
así que uno realmente lo podemos
expresar como 11 que es el módulo por el
ala 2000 y que también es
tropez
y en fin los helados en verdad por iu
y bueno realmente de esta ecuación
entonces obtenemos las raíces por
ejemplo de esta primera x1x cúbica igual
a ea lados
y finalmente x cúbica igual a la y
perdón iguala a la 4 pi y esto es
interesante porque de estas tres vamos a
obtener raíces distintas porque si
sacamos raíz cúbica de ambos lados de la
ecuación digamos de esta sacamos raíz
cúbica de ambos lados de todas las
ecuaciones y después resolvemos para de
x entonces vamos a obtener distintos
resultados por ejemplo en esta primera
en esta tenemos que x es igual a 1 a la
un tercio que es una verdad elevar a la
un tercio saca raíz cúbica de la segunda
es x iguala a la 2 pi a la un tercio
pues en realidad es multiplicar los
exponentes por lo que nos queda a la 2
sobre tres por y muy bien ahora
finalmente de la última tenemos x igual
a la 4 pi y por un tercio que es a la 4
déjeme déjenme rehacer esto con el color
que teníamos les decía que teníamos a la
4 y sobre 3 por iu
muy bien y así podríamos seguir no es
verdad déjenme dejen vamos a detenernos
a pensar un poquito aquí así que
inmediatamente de esto cuál es el
argumento del de la segunda ecuación así
que déjenme escribir
que son tres raíces distintas x 1 x 2 x
3 y bueno vamos a checar la primera raíz
es 1 que es el que ya teníamos verdad
esta es la raíz cúbica de 1 ahora los
otros números son números complejos así
que vamos a visualizar estos números un
poco cuál es el argumento de estos
números para estos la magnitud es 1 y es
1 porque en realidad la r no aparece es
decir que estamos multiplicando por 1
verdad es el coeficiente lo mismo pasa
para el módulo perdón déjenme ponerlo en
azul como estaba el módulo de x 3 pasa
igual es 1 ahora cuál es el argumento de
x 2 digamos y fi es el argumento
entonces es dos tercios ahora cómo
dibujamos este este número complejo x 2
bueno si es de norma 1 quiere decir que
está en el círculo unitario y además hay
que rotar dos tercios
ese es el ángulo en donde se encuentran
dos tercios pues es
dos pies trescientos sesenta y entre
tres son 120 así que se encuentra más o
menos por aquí
justo así
donde este ángulo que estamos marcando
es de 120 grados verdad que es 2 pi
sobre 32 pi sobre 3 y tiene la misma
longitud que x igual a 1 así que este x1
que estoy pintando de verde tiene el
mismo el mismo tamaño que x2 que estoy
pintando en magenta muy bien y sólo
rotamos 120 grados ahora qué pasa con el
segundo cuál es el argumento perdón de x
3 su argumento es 4 p sobre 3 y 4 p son
4 pies 720 y entre 3 pues en real
realmente sólo nos queda que cuanto 720
entre 3
perdón 720 1 724 aquí sería 240 verdad
bueno lo podemos checar y en realidad
son 240 así que le sumamos y fíjense lo
que le faltaba
x2 para llegar al eje real eran 60 así
que con otros 60 tenemos
los 120 que nos faltan es decir si
sumamos tenemos 240 grados que son 4
pitt hercios en radiales es un poquito
engorroso checar esto pero bueno queda
claro que aquí se encuentra el x3 y por
supuesto su enorme es 1 es decir tiene
la misma norma que los otros dos
realmente solo estamos rotando
solo estamos rotando en un ángulo de 120
entre cada uno verdad así que dividimos
el círculo en tres partes iguales lo
cual nos dio que cada uno tiene un
ángulo entre entre cada uno del otro de
120 grados y bueno altura a lo mejor
dices oye tú me prometiste que íbamos a
encontrar raíces complejas pero tú me lo
estás poniendo en su forma exponencial y
yo realmente quiero verlo de la forma
más vil bueno eso simplemente se saca
rápidamente de lo que ya tenemos porque
por ejemplo x2 debido a su forma
exponencial lo pasamos a su forma de
coseno y seno esto es ccoo seno de dos
tercios más y seno de dos tercios verdad
perdón seno de dos tercios y si nos
fijamos ahora en nuestro diagrama bueno
en realidad lo que tenemos de ángulo del
eje imaginario a x2 son 30 grados por lo
que nos quedan 60 grados para este
triángulo verdad así la hipotenusa vale
1 y podemos encontrar rápidamente que la
altura es raíz de 3 sobre 2 y esta
distancia en el eje real es menos un
medio así que vamos a ver esto será
igual a coseno de dos tercios que como
dijimos es menos un medio louis también
sí sí lo hice bien perfecto más y por el
seno de dos tercios que es la altura que
es raíz de tres sobre dos perfecto y
esto multiplica ahí así que éste es x2
hagamos lo mismo con x 3 x 3 va a ser
igual a bueno este valor de x es el
mismo que la anterior pero ahora su
altura será negativa es decir será menos
un medio en un medio verdad y bueno
ahora tenemos este ángulo con respecto a
este ángulo tenemos la misma altura que
x 2 pero en número negativo verdad así
que en este caso tendremos menos la raíz
de tres sobre dos menos la raíz de tres
sobre dos por iu y usando esta técnica
ya pudimos encontrar tres raíces de
nuestra ecuación original tres raíces
complejas estas dos son raíces y también
la raíz 7 igual a 1 es otra raíz también
así que si usamos la misma técnica
podríamos encontrar raíces cuartas
raíces 300 que importan en fin lo único
que sería es dividir el círculo en
varias partes según la potencia de lo
que queramos
o más bien la raíz que queramos sacar
así que si tomamos la raíz de 1 la raíz
cuarta de 1 pues simplemente tomamos
las divisiones del círculo en cuatro
partes verdad ok
ahora te puedes preguntar por qué yo lo
seguí con a las 6 p y por ejemplo así
que si yo hiciera esto fijémonos bien si
x al cubo iguala
a las 6 p y no digamos siguiendo el
mismo argumento anterior
entonces x sería igual a e a la 2
y ya que adivinen qué es lo que teníamos
justamente acá arriba justamente fue
cuando poníamos a la 2 p así que
realmente no era necesario seguirnos con
esa las 6 p bastaba con quedarnos hasta
la 4 pi y de esa forma encontrábamos
tres raíces distintas si querías hallar
la raíz cúbica de uno en realidad es
redundante seguir